demandez toujours deux se trouvent sur
notre obsession monsieur dehors qu'elle
a extrêmement beau extrêmement cool
plaît ok ce parti alors au niveau de
l'histoire du jeu j'en sais foutrement
un je vous avoue je crois que justice
lève la nuit comme ça une sorte de
couteau trobador dans une étagère un
seul famille on est père d'un petit
garçon de cinq ans extrêmement flippant
il est déjà posséder avant même d'être
adulte et notre femme on voit pas son
visage elle est brûlée finalement comme
les filles sur les sept grammes qui font
des photos avec une correction des
couleurs un peu trop poussé alors au h à
l'espace avant je retourne dans mon lit
immédiatement je pleurais ont pensé
annonce assez fermé fermer quoi ces lots
kessel-lo cas chacun a en tout cas c'est
très beau j'adore ce [ __ ] de moteur
graphique aussi un livre ville de in
route
c'est l'allemand donc ma femme n'est pas
là la femme népalaise suis mon fils est
là on va aller voir dans sa petite
chambre va pas se mentir je ratisse tout
va l'appeler où es-tu jean baptiste on
va monter au ya le bruit d'une boîte à
musique mon gars c'est jean baptiste qui
est en train de jouer mieux dormir c'est
ça on va aller engueuler jean baptiste
seller de donno pourquoi il faut encore
la boîte à musique jean m'a dit tu te
fout de la gueule de qui jean bat à
[ __ ] je n'aime pas ça c'est l'apport
de des accès fermés je suis enfermé
non-médecin black hole - si ce fou de
bayonne jean baptiste et là au moins dix
fois que jean baptiste est là donc on
doit prendre la boîte à musique s'est
clos voilà voilà il ya des signes qui
apparaissent quand je le vois et je peux
m'appuyer sur eux pour interagir avec
les symboles
je lui dise que ça fait mais en tout cas
jean
oh c'est glauque au c'est glauque et
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça adéquiste
amoureuses mais pas du tout mec s'attend
à tout cas lui la hâte en valais le voir
directement gars tu arrêtes canton
canular oh non le bad ya symbole là on
va interagir avec lui aussi au la joue
mes choux je zappe lac un média élabore
des disparus arrêté qu'en séparant foule
à plus tard une grosse cette porte mène
au placard et le placard mène à cette
porte là où ça fait mal alors au nouveau
symbole
ok on interagit peut paraître injuste
avec le symbole il faut trouver un
deuxième symbole qui correspond à ça je
pense qu'il doit y est pas là il est là
mais que s'y trouvent à dos c'est trop
bien fait alors c'est donc ça ses
dessins de mon fils
d'accord va tout va bien là pas de
problème moi mon fils il fait un dessin
comme ça un jour c'est plus mon fils je
vous dis c'est quoi ce bruit c'est la
télé ya de la neige c'est ça ta part
soir à zurich une fille qui semble apte
et les automates hard vient toucher le
tt ca ta pas cool t'as pas de couture
est consciente à neige dans ta télé à
lens tient cette fois je vais pouvoir
ouvrir ça va mener à un brillant droit
ou pas oui c'est bon non c'est le même
placard ne mixe amour et d oui j'irai
bruit gd oui
vodafone ya des bruits étranges ta boîte
mais qui doit d'ici là [ __ ] dondon to
be dont on passe dix d'or mais c'est ma
femme j'allais pas quand je vais t'aider
[ __ ] j'suis en loge loulou poule
jallet jacqueline fois biens sociaux
béton fait par colt à main contre la
porte je colle mamao si on fait un câlin
travers la porte jacqueline c'était
l'avant et badauds
voilà quoi ya encore plus de dessins
toujours aussi bas dans n'y a pas de
hasard et les bruits d'une autre beauté
musique alors que j'ai arrêté ma boîte à
musique ils veulent nous retourner le
cerveau ça marchera pas j'ai tout à fait
ouverte mais c'est mon fils qui s'est
barré [ __ ] on habite au 9e étage il
est mort ce qu'on doit avoir décidé à
mon avis mais ou sur les voies y a pas
un titre zizou poser mec assis il y en
avait un [ __ ] voilà et de 1up le
deuxième on l'a et ne manquent pas trois
wah wah wah stop it stop et roche sa
boîte à musique [ __ ] pyatt hockey
what you're gonna do we dernier single
est pas là haut et la [ __ ] été trouvé
à cacher mais choqué le si le muc âgée
du monde
ok c'est fait on va pouvoir passer la
porte on captage me chie dessus elle
nous fait pas ton s'en va et on
passeront de surin stone débarque comme
d'hab cette porte mène dans cette pièce
ça tu as tu bien en geste ou clean ce
qui n'est pas trop rassurant allez un
peu par l'éclat d'assas et dont on fait
ça ils sont une famille c'est rire
l'éclat de rire des abonnez vous où
es-tu ça va payer leur bruit à il se
cachait derrière les cintres aux [ __ ]
ça part en couilles mais [ __ ] ça va
encore ça part en couilles au haut point
what is a baby a éclos ce genre alpagué
close au clown aux jo c'est quoi ce
bordel mais je crois pas à coup je passe
la porte france ouais je me doute que
c'est ça a mon avis oui parce qu'on y
retrouve à sept cordes et on est de
retour le placard ce qui se passe ça
c'est des plats salés lorie kane
assas et villa le gesù sur le mur suit
est un cauchemar
[ __ ] m'annonce que je penserais pas du
tout au même endroit à cochons vont
travailler sur notre plancher avec alors
bas si on s'est juste endormi sur son
canapé devant inspecteurs aller les
premiers signes trouvé d'accord donc
ensuite qu'on a retrouvé trois s'il
n'aura accès au couteau alors un signe
ouais c'est quoi ça ouais ouais ya un
monstre a été sérieux de sérieux on
dirait de marbre je peux pas à fils de
[ __ ] barrette mais ça s'est vu mettez le
client la gorge obtient pas de monter
son côté annoncé que ya cinq signes est
retrouvé en plus de mettre la musique du
coup ça va la tirer mais non bienvenue
ou pas il ya vu un signe à ok super tu
t'en prends je range ta boîte à musique
est parti le monde il est plus à choix
sebbar et on est bien on est mis en
effet en les battant le mans s'est fait
sans tuer s'ils arrivent pas passé le
matin je m'en bats les couilles un lien
synamec [ __ ] on a bien fait de monter
mon gars on était hyper mal à regarder
il ya ainsi la bâche n'entend pas que tu
n'aurais pas dû faire ça harriet d'aquin
qu'est ce que j'ai fait qu'est ce que
les faits monsieur rillettes
non mais c'est quoi ce bruit jospeh de
l'accusé n'en n'ont joué qu'une seule
envie question jamais rien à manic et
aptitudes truc de famille pour le nickel
on l'a eu en fait y en avait sept avoir
fait à chaque fois il y en a si nous en
manque un
2 al hawa fier ce [ __ ] de jeu sans
brouillon de ce soir tu sers que les
deux derniers sont vérifiées pas loin du
monstre à ouattara va forcément réussie
de cimenter pas la regarder le long du
lit ça s'est fait à l'aube russes et du
premier il est où il est où on en est
plus à nos actes nos au phoque
je me couche c'est un cauchemar là ça va
il est évident qu'il est débile il a
l'air de murray regardez au [ __ ]
comment je fais comment je fais il va se
marier ou penser on va attendre on va
tant pis ce thème non tenues fois
c'est un cauchemar ghanéen vient de se
réveiller c'est fini le jeu est terminé
ah bah non c'est faux pour moi ça
sauvegarder les six qu'on avait pris
nous en reste plus qu'un à mon avis doit
être vers l'accusé n'a bien autour du
monde vous savez également ce soin est
allé s'en est allée est parti loin pour
user et signe je rêvais en colère après
[ __ ] au le signe grâce à ces petites
plaques à induction ça ça chauffe deux
fois plus vite
là dans le bas car c'est comme s'il y en
a ah oui oh oui oh là là ça n'est
qu'ensuite c'est ça la le monde suivait
très naïve est debout
j'ai eu peur j'ai peur pourquoi j'ai eu
peur ya forcément une raison j'ai jamais
peur pour rien fuck it works facchetti
cacher je cache cache et ne doit pas
nous ment pas il s'est barré ou pas
alors on se tient aussi à apprendre le
couteau ont valu planter dans le coeur
ok mais là rien fait lui aussi les
parties il a f k mondiale on prends le
couteau au oui dans son petit coeur
ouais ouais tu me mets dans son coeur
ouais ouais
allez allez oui mais la mission
française la baïonnette
elle a découpé c'est fini
ou c'est nous qui avons perdu non
seulement on l'a eue on lie le pont
[Musique]
rial le fist fish eye avec le fils du
maple arrêté regardez le fils son visage
et trouvez donc qu'en fait c'était son
fils qui a été transformée doit toujours
y abonner vous s'il vous plaît voilà je
suis atteint de terminaux sur note
s'échelonnent un petit journée comme on
les adore [ __ ] il libère mon
graphiquement au niveau du gameplay mais
quatre ou un truc innovant qui est très
très sympathique j'aurais juste aimé
clément sont un peu plus vers qui nous
terrifie bien comme il faut comme un
certain aliens de alien isolation alors
surtout à bruxelles ne sais pas d'où ça
vous a plu
c'est ce que je vous ai déjà demandé ont
semblé ce texte batum lympia de monde
mais ça c'était not of pop séssion
[Musique]